when i see cnn going on tv and attacking
just blanket blanket attacks i'm like
they really don't get it
right they're absolutely trying their
hardest to inflame
tensions they don't care that what they
do
makes everything worse and you the best
part is you know you know i love the
most
i have these people who tweeted me
saying like you you helped cause this
tim
like your videos your content and i'm
like you mean every single video where
i've said violence doesn't work and it's
bad for everybody who does it
this is what's amazing that we can have
a show like this where repeatedly say
violence doesn't work
non-violent civil disobedience is one of
the most effective things because we're
in
fifth generational warfare maybe you can
talk about violent revolution in the
1700s
but when it comes to today's day and age
it's all about perception and fifth
generational warfare
the problem is cnn what did what did who
was it was it cuomo
was it cuomo who was like and who says
protests need to be peaceful
bruce cuomo said who said protests need
to be peaceful and that gave birth to
ramen guy
you guys remember ramen guy right and
he's eating the ramen and he goes it's
right there in the first amendment mr
cuomo
yes it is right yeah he's got to look it
up now what are they saying
oh it's insurrection we knew these
trumpers would do it
well i'll tell you man i have no idea
what these people were thinking because
they're not going to win anything this
is going to be
this is going to be a big crack down
from the security statement in may they
burned down the guard
tower in the white house again we
shouldn't really be comparing the two
but we should
note that that events are being
manipulated information
is being hidden from you it's being
editorialized to push an agenda
and that agenda is for you guys to fight
each other speaking of the video of the
girl
standing up on the door you retweeted it
yeah it was from she's on the door
she's like standing like this on the
door yeah she's right on the door and
she gets hit and knocked back it got
removed from twitter oh they removed
interesting yeah i'm looking at it right
now i can see it in my feed and then
when i go to the i just retweeted it and
it was removed right
all right so here's the thing this is
why it's not the same this is why may is
not the same this is why today was a
mistake but i want to say first off that
i understand i understand why people are
upset i understand why they want to rage
i understand why they feel like
i understand why black lives matter
wants to raise totally i understand why
they feel like this may be the last
chance to have a republic if this is the
end if they have it you know
clean sweep of the legislature and the
presidency it's gonna be gone the rest
of the country's gonna be gone i
understand
why people would feel upset the
difference is
is that the maga insurrection
the maga revolution the maga network is
not in alignment with the corporations
it's not in alignment with the media and
so
when black lives matter and antifa are
so black lives matter and antifa they
can go do this exact kind of thing
and get a favorable reaction to their
tribe and still maintain their moral
victory within their tribe
we try to do it and it's instantly going
to get shot down we have no media
backing we've got no actual narrative
backing on this
and it's counterproductive and it's
damaging to these people these people
that ran into the capitol
prison prison this dude was running
around
with like the the stand you know like
the day or smiling at the camera and i
was like bro you're going to prison
for a long like prison and it was just
today an hour ago at the speech trump
goes
and you know what we made it 10 years to
mess with any of our federal monuments
or buildings or whatever the case so
like 10 years dude you're going to
prison 10 years yep
10 years and so it's not going to work
we have to have
the right has to have a different
strategy
than the left and the left strategy
means that the tactics they can use
are things like have riots burn down
buildings
antagonize the police do all these
things because they get echoed in
support from the corporations maga
cannot do it because the net result is a
negative it's not
a positive nothing was gained today only
things were lost
today and the people who lost that girl
lost her life
those people are gonna lose their
freedom they're gonna go to prison
and we are all gonna lose liberty come
this new administration when they use
this as the new
impetus for the double down triple extra
hard patriot act
that's coming right up your ass well
chuck schumer is comparing what happened
today to pearl harbor
so yes we're going to have a lot of
politicians
uh milking this cow until until
it has come home until the roosters come
home i think it's bad and i just
i just want to finish this thought i've
been catching a lot of creep on twitter
today because i've been recommending
that people
women and children and non-combatants
get out of dc tonight because it's not
safe
i've been recommending that people stay
out of trouble and stay out of harm's
way and not commit violence and not
commit crimes
why because it's not the right tactic
today all it's going to do is do
harm to you there has to be other
strategies we're working on them i'm
personally working on them we have
networks people work on it
but we can't mimic what the other side
is doing because they have a completely
different
ground high ground or not they just have
the corporations in the media and it all
works together here's an analogy
imagine you control the high ground so
your strategy is to aim
down and fire yeah and imagine if then
the trump supporters all see them up on
top of the hill pointing their guns down
and go we should point our guns down too
and they all or if they're like they're
using throwing rocks as a tactic if you
have a high ground it works
but the people on the bottom can't use
throwing rocks as a tactic because they
can't get the rocks up there
but that's the point like they're a
little different the antifa
and the leftists like like jack said
have corporations on their side
trump supporters don't it's not a tactic
you can use gravity yeah
we watched black lives matter get record
support after george floyd and then they
lit
it on fire when they rioted and i've
made so many videos saying this proves
this should be the proof to everybody
violence does
not work again we can talk about the
boston tea party we can talk about the
1700s
but we are in the information age fifth
generational warfare is about
manipulation tactics and propaganda
and that means they'll find a picture of
you wiping your butt and be like look
what he's doing and they'll post it
everywhere act like it's the end of the
world
but antifa can throw a brick at
someone's face and they're gonna be like
it's a peaceful protest
in fourth or fifth generation war there
are there are additional layers to the
combat
space that there was before besides
being just physical there's mental and
moral
and in our environment the moral plane
is one of the most
important ones to win it's not about a
moral victory and that's something that
you get even though you lost
it's not about keeping the moral high
ground about taking some sort of
highfalutin you know and you know your
integrity in some some regard
it's about just winning the moral war as
in having the support
of the people as in having the people on
your side
as in leading people it's not and not
pushing people away
storming the capital is going to push
away people who you need the support of
what this is
i think they i think they uh uh well
i'll i'll stop where i was gonna say i'm
gonna say this the cops are on video
opening up the barricade i saw that i
said and a lot of people
are saying no no no that was different
that was different that wasn't the same
moment as when they were
pushing on the cops and shaking the
barricades and pulling them down but it
was a moment where the police opened up
the barricades and then you hear
people yelling they're just letting them
into the capital they're
opening up the capital building to these
people like they're they're at the
capitol building when they did this
there's there's a video a photo going
around of cbp
and like locking down and like they're
like we're
we are sending out cbp officers to guard
the capital while these protests and
riots are going on
so a lot of people are asking why is it
that this time when we knew
trump was saying come on down it'll be
wild
we knew that the media kept saying over
and over again trump is instigating
violence and i left i was like trump
said come protest he didn't say do
anything
you're calling it instigating and then
the police weren't there with enough
force or presence to do anything to stop
this let alone
them opening up the barricades it's i
mean it's better than them
slowing down the crowd no no no listen
when
when when the when the black lives
matter people were there they had
uh police riot police with shields
lining the streets this time
they had a couple of cops with batons
why was that why do you think they let
them in no idea
i don't know there's a number of
different access points to the capitol
grounds that was just one of them there
were people scaling walls there was
another time i saw them fighting for the
gates i mean
i i have no idea what happened there i'm
gonna i'm gonna try to
find also another thing that i think
really people need to kind of think
about here
why are people surprised when the
establishment the mainstream media the
corporations politicians codified and
normalized
violence as a way to get political power
just a few weeks ago
this is something that's becoming the
new norm we've been calling it out no
matter who does it
and and people are of course making
arguments saying if they did it we could
do it too and again that's
that's not a good logic it's not new
norm it's the old norm
it's the norm norm it's the norm norm i
mean has it hasn't been
this prevalent uh as of as of late i
mean we could make historical art
historically
all throughout but as of late i think
that's what that's something that's
important is just a few weeks ago
like well specifically when we were
talking about you know black lives
matter
let's let's bring them up here in a
specific context they got billions of
dollars they got institutional support
they had major corporations major
politicians supporting them that's
after committing violent acts
we'll talk about the differences here
literally paid so the first thing is
these are trump supporters who who shut
down and breached the electoral college
vote count for the presidency it's
serious but it was one time and it was i
think 300 people they estimated
black lives matter was what three weeks
of nationwide riots
over two billion dollars in damage and
30 people dead or something
30 plus it was yeah 30 plus people died
in the riots not all from
rioters but in rising they were under
reported and confiscated even by the
reporting by michael tracy who went out
there and covered that the damage was
far bigger than we even knew about it
and then how much money did black lives
matter bring in it was
that billion ten billion billion dollars
they were given
money what lesson does that teach the
average person out there who's paying
attention what lesson does that kind of
show
what works to the average destroying
private property is okay but if you mess
with government property
it's not okay right it should be it
should be the other way around exactly
exactly yeah that's it well and then and
you know you said that
that the uh the left lit the goodwill on
fire that they gained through the
the protests earlier this year i think
that that's not entirely true
as i was downtown i noted i every time i
looked up
each building had a giant black lives
matter banner on it the churches have
them covering it you know the
it's it's everywhere they it's like they
they they won they won in dc
that's for sure black lives matter has
not extinguished any of its support
it is not burned through uh that that
capital that it earned aside from the 10
billion dollars
and if you can't take any lesson at all
it's like you do that but that's the
problem they were baited we were baited
into behaving like antifa and black
lives matter when we cannot
it is counterproductive to our strategy
let me back this up
correct yes i think you're right that
people do generally support black lives
matter
but i have a graph here that i want
people to see which i've shown before
from civics
black lives matter registered voters do
you support or oppose the black lives
matter movement
right after the george floyd incident
net support for black
i'm sorry right before george floyd lost
his life net support for black lives
matter was at 18
so that means like above the the the
margin like above 50
when the when the protests spiked 24
net support and the riots started before
remember before george floyd black lives
matters enjoyed 18
the riots hit and it dropped from 24 all
the way down
to eight percent where it currently sits
right now eight percent
they had 18 they lost 10 percent of
their net support in this country by
rioting
and it has not come back so they do
enjoy
general support on average in this
country but there was a point where even
conservatives were like i understand
this george floyd thing was really bad
then they went and burned down mom and
pop shops yeah it's not like the mogan
network went into this scene at the
capitol building with credit goodwill
credit in the bank
exactly they already went in negative oh
and money on the run
from the debtor the creditors trying to
chase them down and then they go and
then they they they just
chop their face off man but you know so
i i replayed her you put that down with
one of these guys like a really
well-known q conspiracy guy like the
viking guy has been seen at events
holding up signs for q
some people are trying to claim these
black lives matter and well he may have
been at an event but they cropped out
there's a photo i see going around and
you can't see what the sign says it's
cropped out
you sent me and it yes it said i think
it pretty much says that literally it
says q sent me oh yeah that's the sign
that he has there
there's a there's a meme of him now and
it has that famous picture and it says
when you ordered the village people from
wish
and then it's a picture of him and all
the other people standing in the
background there
but again a lot of disinformation a lot
of people just manipulating facts
editorializing so they could push a
certain agenda
and when we just stop looking at these
agendas we see a very
uh very very bad picture of more
fuel on the fire and that's exactly
what's happening with all the reporting
supposedly
that's going on today with again just
trying to get as much disinformation
trying to get as much propaganda trying
to brainwash people to make you
understand
that guy's going to hurt you you need to
fight him at all costs and now we're
here at this stage and we're not going
to be going away anytime soon
because the algorithms that incentivize
it the mainstream media that spews it
the politicians who allow it they're the
ones who are still sadly
at the helms and are going to be
expanding it and pushing this to a level
that
is it's going to become more and more
unlivable and more and more
apparent whatever the conditions were
that launched trump into presidency in
2016
are today now and going to get much
worse
than they were in 2015 it's going to be
worse than the last term of the obama
presidency
they've got more money they're better
established they've taken over more
institutions
it's more in our schools it's more in
our kids our kids our kids are just
reciting things without even
understanding it
so if you didn't like the way things
were before i have a feeling you're not
going to like them very much in the next
ladies uh google has disabled chat on
this stream
what's that for obvious reasons get out
of town
chat has been disabled so uh no more
chat for people who are watching but
they're allowing the stream to continue
because i guess
i guess because our conversation is is
calm and reasonable and you know we're
very much very anti-violent but chad's
saying
we're not even making any allegations
we're not telling you what other people
are saying chad has been disabled for
things that people are saying they can't
control and we can't moderate
wow so they're shutting it down wow okay
welcome to
whatever is coming next i got no idea
we're watching it in action but i i just
got contacted by google right now that
uh we
we noticed chat wasn't working okay
and uh yeah so we're making argument
arguments against radicalization no no
it's not on us the streams okay
yeah the checking gets yeah but you
still you still get punished because
again people come to engage people talk
to people want to have those
conversations and they can't right now
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you